welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and we just got our first trailer
for
shangshi and the legend of the ten rings
marvel's new martial arts film coming
september following the hero of shangshi
simulu
and his battles with the mandarin a
villain that we thought we were gonna
see in iron man 3 but that guy was just
a fake and now we are seeing the real
mandarin though he's going by many names
in this anyway i don't know why i'm
saying there's a trailer to react to so
i'm gonna react to it give you my first
thoughts and then tomorrow i'm gonna
have my brain by frame breakdown of all
the easter eggs we missed in this
trailer so here we
go
kill bill maybe that's fun
damn that's not easy i gave you 10 years
to live your life
oh cool i like that mystery
and where did that get you
you walked in my shadow
oh
this looks great i trained you
see the most dangerous people in the
world
couldn't kill you
[Music]
yeah it's bracelets cool okay
music's great
oh man nice
what you can't
[Applause]
ah this looks sick
music's great
[Music]
we make a good team that's why you don't
street park into your deli square in sf
whoa this looks great this is exactly
what i wanted from this film because
yeah without the marvel logo
most people wouldn't really recognize
this as a marvel film and that's a point
that's why it's gonna be great it's
gonna be a breath of fresh share really
the character of shanxi from the 70s
comics was inspired by bruce lee's enter
the dragon
like arguably his most famous kung fu
film and really marvel was just trying
to build on the popularity of that in
the early 70s so at the sides of shangxi
the most important character to point
out is tony liang playing the character
known as win woo
that is his father but according to
kevin feige and the writer and the
director
he's also going to be the mandarin a
character who is ancient who has gone by
many names over the centuries really in
the comics simulu's father is a
character that was originally known as
fu manchu
a very problematic character for a lot
of reasons who in the modern era was
updated to the name of zhang zhu
kind of a father-son relationship son
being the hero father being the villain
but rather than it being a big twist
shanxi knew who his father was and
decided to leave for that reason trying
to find a new life in america but now
he's being dragged back into this
but before we continue thank you to our
friends at seed for sponsoring this
video
seed has created this daily symbiotic
that helps support
gut health which is something that we
all want and if you haven't thought
about it congratulations you're probably
like nine years old and everything has
always worked for you
so seeds daily synbiotic is a prebiotic
plus a probiotic and it was developed
for benefits beyond just digestive
health it helps support heart health
skin health and micronutrient synthesis
in your tumtum
it's got 24 strain broad spectrum
probiotic and prebiotic formulated for
digestive
gut immunity and additional systemic
benefits 53.6 billion afu
that translates roughly to it's got the
goods its special capsule technology
protects against stomach acid and other
things in your digestive tract to ensure
the live probiotics make it to the end
of your small intestine where they will
do their thing
it is sustainably delivered monthly with
each component of their refill system
designed to protect your daily symbiotic
and be gentler on our earth i've started
taking the synbiotic every day and i'm
feeling
good i'm excited to see how it will
support my health over a longer period
get 15
off your first month's supply of seeds
daily symbiotic by using code new
rockstars at checkout
click the link in the description below
to get started and here we're starting
to get a sense of the legend of
the ten rings which are not going to be
the 10 pieces of mcluhan tech that wrap
around your fingers
but rather interesting bracelets five on
each hand i would imagine which i
actually kind of prefer because it
removes it from like the knuckle jewelry
that the infinity stones were
the ten rings is a criminal organization
that's existed since the first iron man
that was the group that was behind
raza the terrorists that kidnapped tony
stark we also know that they were in
iron man 2. they were the group who gave
iron vanco his paperwork and iron man 3
we thought we were getting the mandarin
but that was really just british actor
trevor slattery and then there was a
short called all hail the king which is
technically m stew cannon in which
trevor slattery is visited in prison by
an agent of the ten rings
breaks him out of prison and says that
the real mandarin wants his name and his
reputation back and also there's an
easter egg to the ten rings in ant-man
one of the guys who wanted his hands on
that pym tech actually had a tin rings
tattoo but yeah these guys have been
around the whole time and now we're
gonna see who's really behind them all
which is going to be when woo
in this trailer we see him apparently in
ancient battles in ancient times so he's
kind of a semi-immortal character
she is just his son in the modern era
there's a great shot of when we
kind of slide into the center of the
frame right in the center of the ten
rings on the imprint behind him
also when the helicopter lands yeah
there's that ten rings logo on the
ground there with what looks like an
army of ninjas and operatives
so yeah it sounds like shanxi is being
lured back into this fighting tournament
that's hosted by his father wenwu aka
the mandarin
also fighting in that is going to be
fighter florian montyanu
big nasty he's playing a character that
we think is razor fist i mean there's
really not that much to the character
he's just one of these other assassins
from the shangshi comics there's also
this masked ninja that we believe is
death dealer
xing lin looks like another assassin who
works for the mandarin in that ten rings
organization
menger zhang is playing jai ling that
shang shi's sister
also daughter to win woo aquafina is
playing his friend katie
ronnie chang is also another one of
their friend nsf i mean i'm loving the
fight choreography of this like it's
looking like a fusion of lots
of different martial arts cinematography
from the comedic slapstick martial arts
that jackie chan would do
the more epic fantasy wire work that
you'd see in crouching tiger hidden
dragon
there's shots of this amazing looking
ancient war with these
lions fighting alongside them and they
kind of have the design of the
lion dancing monsters in chinese culture
they aren't
modern lions they're like these ancient
fantasy beasts i mean look folks any mcu
film that can bring more magic into the
universe whether it's dr
strange or black panther i'm here for it
i'm ready for this universe to get more
mystical those are my first thoughts
there's a lot of interesting details in
this trailer that i want to point out so
i'm going to take some time go through
it frame by frame hopefully by tomorrow
i'll have a breakdown for you we got a
lot of stuff in the pipeline but i'm so
excited to have this trailer i'm excited
to see how this fits into the mcu we
know it to be right now
how it moves the mcu forward in all
kinds of ways
you can get your hands on our new
rockstar's latest obsession shirt this
is anarchy assembled and inspired by the
falcon the winter soldier
at newrockstarsmerch.com you can follow
me at ea boss follow me rockstar
subscribe to rockstars for breakdowns of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
you